depuis que le gouvernement a annoncé le
prélèvement à la source ce service du
groupe pierre marie joseph se prépare on
anticipe et je dirais depuis
six mois à peu près six mois pour
permettre de l'arrivée à la mesure
progressivement et vous avez en secret
de quelle manière exactement
eh bien
voilà par des échanges mardi veille
sociale par les
voilà des formations aussi nous sommes
évidemment aux services de paie quatre
personnes y travaillent pour établir
plus de deux mille bulletins de salaire
par mois
autant de documents sur lesquels il va
falloir rajouter dès le 1er janvier 2019
une ligne celle de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour le responsable du service cela
induit une série d'ajustements
il faut se préparer il faut anticiper
ses formes et mettre à jour les
logiciels pour qu'on sera prêt au 1er
janvier 2019 des formations pour tous
les agents de son service donc l'achat
d'un nouveau logiciel puis la mise à
jour de ce même logiciel mais aussi
l'embauché d'un agent supplémentaire au
service paye afin de gérer les
sollicitations éventuelles des salariés
inquiets par le prélèvement à la source
tout ceci va nous coûter au bas mot à
mon avis entre 50 et 100 mille euros
sans compter le temps passé le temps
passé par le par la direction
déjà et le personnel encadrant soit plus
de 45 euros par salarié et par an mais
ce n'est pas ce coût supplémentaire
supporté par le groupe qui interpelle le
plus le patron il faudrait surtout qu'au
niveau des services des finances que
nous ayons certainement vers différents
quelqu'un qui puisse en permanence être
en contact avec nous en cas de problème
qu'ils puissent être ambitieux être
sollicités pour que nous soyons
effectivement accompagné et surtout que
certains nombre de problèmes soient
résolus parce que vous savez quand on
touche à la paye c'est quand même très
compliqué il faut il faut faire très
attention donc
car les salariés acceptent très mal
effectivement qu'il y ait des couacs au
niveau de leurs de l'europe et ses
couacs
la cinquantaine de sociétés composant le
groupe gp mj saura donc l'algérie
mais qu'en est il des très petites
petites et moyennes entreprises
individuelles constituant l'essentiel du
tissu économique martiniquais
sauront-elles comme le groupe pierre
marie josèphe supporter un coût annuel
supplémentaire de 45 euros par salarié